hi everyone I'm Alana and welcome to my
channel and today we are going to talk
about the fact that there has been 16
hours of motion-capture sex recorded for
The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt I don't know
exactly how that works but I hope you'll
join me in picturing some guy inside of
a green screen one of those real suits
with balls on them just thrusting at
things for hours because how else do
they capture motion sex right it's just
a hilarious image but sex has always
been a really controversial topic in
videogames particularly because of
ratings I think Rockstar actually wanted
to include sexy in grand theft auto san
andreas but decided to take it out of
the game so that they could keep the
rating low enough for children to be
able to buy it of course they didn't
fully remove it because people later
found those files within the game and
unlocked them which caused the hot
coffee controversy basically people
figured out how to have sex in San
Andreas and a lot of people were really
angry about that so the witch on the
other hand has chosen to include well
probably not 16 hours of sex but I mean
they've chosen to include some degree of
six apparently the game even starts off
with the sex scene and I don't remember
it exactly but I feel like The Witcher 2
may have done a similar thing or at
least as a sex scene very close to this
out of the game and I don't understand
why this is a problem in any way
whatsoever movies have sex scenes books
have plenty of sex scenes why is it only
an issue when it comes to video games
maybe if it's interactive and it changes
the rating but usually it's not but we
seem to be kind of terrified of having
mature content in games the fact that
everyone is talking about this and some
people are really angry about the
inclusion and I think that is the main
point or reason that I wanted to make
this video is to say I think that if The
Witcher 3 or 2 exists in a world that
didn't have any sex that would be an
unrealistic world think about how big
and dynamic that si Projekt RED have
told us that the game is going to be it
would be a lie to not have sex in that
universe pretty sure that Geralt would
get down but even if he wouldn't sex can
be used as a really powerful tool in
storytelling and not at all in a bad way
it automatically tells you when
characters are connected to one another
which is apparently how the first
scene in The Witcher 3 is actually being
used to tell you that there's a
relationship between two characters and
that it's important and that you should
care about the woman involved because
they need you to care quickly enough to
move the game along but it can also
cause conflict and it can be involved in
politics as we've all seen with Game of
Thrones it's a really powerful narrative
tool and plot device and also a part of
virtually every other fiction so I don't
see the problem man whether being
overexposed to sex and fictional media
could be harmful to children someway I
don't know but it comes back to a point
I made in a recent GTA 5 video which
I'll link below if you want to see my
points on that it's basically if you
don't want kids to see it don't buy it
for them there are ratings on these
games for a reason they can't buy it
without their parents doing it for them
so if you don't want them to see 16
hours of motion captured sex and just
buy them the game man as much as I don't
care all that much about seeing and it
kind of makes me happy that this is
being taken seriously as again a
narrative tool in a medium that is now
becoming really really mature and for
adults it's like CD Projekt RED have
recognized that adults are a large
portion of their audience and are
actually taking that seriously now I'm
sick of video games being perceived as
being the children because they're not
anymore even though kids games are also
fantastic and children who are gamers
are generally pretty cool to Minecraft
everywhere but I guess this is just a
short video where I wanted to share that
I'm happy about this inclusion I think
it's realistic I think that if this is
the medium and I think it's a really
good narrative tool that we should be
utilizing in video games maybe not in
like stuff like coal of Judy if they
throw it in there it's kind of weird but
in giant RPGs go for it
but I don't even know what you guys
think are you one of the people who's
really outraged I still don't really
understand the logic behind that one I'm
Alana thank you guys for watching I'll
see you next
[Music]